>> Katie: BACKLASH BUILDING
OVER NEW YORK CITY, NEW YORK,
CITY-BASED PSYCHIATRIST SAYING
SHE FANTASIZES ABOUT KILLING
WHITE PEOPLE DURING A SPEECH AT
YALE UNIVERSITY.
MAKING THOSE EXPLOSIVE COMMENTS
IN A GUEST LECTURE TO MEDICAL
STUDENTS BACK IN APRIL.
>> ANY WHITE PERSON THAT GOT IN
MY WAY.
LIKE I DID THE WORLD A BLEEPING
FAVOR.
WE ARE ASKING VIOLENT PREDATOR
WHO THINKS THEY ARE A SUPERHERO
TO ACCEPT RESPONSIBILITY.
IT AIN'T GONNA HAPPEN.
>> Katie: THE PSYCHIATRIST
CLAIMS SHE WAS TAKING OUT TAKING
OUT OUT OF CONTEXT AND WAS TAKEN
METAPHORICALLY AND YALE IS
BACKTRACKING AND SAYING THOSE
COMMENTS ARE ANTITHETICAL OF
THOSE VALUES IN THE UNIVERSITY
REPORTEDLY RESTRICTED ONLINE
VIEWING AFTER IT HAPPENED SO IT
SEEMS LIKE THE DOCTOR NEEDS A
DOCTOR.
>> Dana: THIS CLASS SHE WAS
TEACHING WAS ONE THAT WOULD
ALLOW YOU TO GET YOUR LICENSE
AND CREDIT SO ONE OF THE ONES
YOU HAD TO TAKE.
THIS IS THE KIND OF THING THAT
IS ALLOWED, IF YOU WANTED TO
BECOME A PSYCHIATRIST YOU COULD
GO TO THIS LECTURE AND TAKE HER
CLASS.
I READ THAT ENTIRE INTERVIEW SHE
DID AND I HAVE TO SAY, I'M NOT A
PSYCHIATRIST OBVIOUSLY BUT I
WOULD SAY THIS PERSON IS INSANE
IN THE BACK THAT YALE TRIED TO
SUPPRESS VIEWS, IS THAT
CENSORSHIP?
THEY KNEW THAT IT COULD CAUSE A
BIG PROBLEM, I CAN'T IMAGINE
THEY WANT THIS KIND OF PERSON
THERE.
SOME PEOPLE MIGHT THINK, THAT'S
JUST ONE LADY.
IT'S JUST ONE LADY AND IT'S NOT
REPRESENTATIVE BUT WHEN YOU
THINK ABOUT HOW MUCH WE ARE ALL
TALKING IN THE COUNTRY ABOUT
CRITICAL RACE THEORY AND
CURRICULUMS BEING SUGGESTED FOR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY IN THIS TYPE OF THING IS
HAPPENING IN THE UNIVERSITIES,
WHERE THEY GO NEXT?
THEY GRADUATE.
>> Katie: SHE MAKES A POINT
THAT THIS IS THE CLASS YOU CAN
TAKE FOR CREDIT, YOU ARE
SUPPOSED TO TAKE WHAT SHE SANG
SERIOUSLY AND AS IT IS SOMETHING
THAT SHOULD BE CREDIBLE IN TERMS
OF AN ARGUMENT BUT BASICALLY
WHAT SHE'S SAYING IS YOU'RE
ALLOWED TO MURDER WHITE PEOPLE
FOR THE SAKE OF THEM BEING
WHITE.
IT SOUNDS PRETTY RACIST TO ME.
IS IT RACIST?
IT IS.
>> Geraldo: AT FIRST OF ALL,
THIS ABSOLUTELY CONFIRMS MY
THEORY THAT ALL PSYCHIATRISTS
ARE CRAZY.
'S BEFORE YOU JUST A
WHOLE GROUP.
>> Geraldo: I JUST DID, I
SMEARED THE WHOLE GROUP.
THIS CASUAL HATRED IS VERY
TROUBLING AND UNDERLINES A LOT
OF WHAT'S OUT THERE RIGHT NOW
WHERE YOU HAVE, TALK ABOUT
CRITICAL RACE THEORY, YOU HAVE
CRITICAL RACE RELATIONS GOING ON
ALL OVER THE PLACE, THIS UNDER
THAT ONE AND THIS ONE WITHOUT
ONE.
I THINK IT'S VERY, VERY
TROUBLING.
I WAS A FELLOW AT YALE, NAMED
AFTER SENATOR JOHN C CALHOUN
FROM THE EARLY 19TH CENTURY WHO
WAS A RACIST, APPARENTLY,
JOHN KENNEDY SAID HE WAS ONE OF
THE GREAT SENATORS EVER, THEY
REDISCOVERED HE WAS A RACIST A
FEW YEARS AGO SO THEY CHANGED
THE NAME OF CALHOUN COLLEGE
WHERE I WAS A CALHOUN FELLOW AND
YOU KNOW, I QUIT.
I QUIT BECAUSE IT WAS SO
GRATUITOUS.
IT WAS SO -- THEY WERE SO
POLITICALLY CORRECT AND TO
LAUNCH THIS PERSON AND THEN
ATTEMPT TO COVER IT UP.
IT'S NEVER THE CRIME, IT'S
ALWAYS A COVER UP AND I SAY
THAT, I HAVE A BEAUTIFUL
THIRD-YEAR LAW STUDENT AT YALE,
MY DAUGHTER, I'M VERY PROUD OF
THE ASSOCIATION BUT THIS WOMAN
IS --
>> Greg: IT IS HOW MANY MINES
HAS SHE TOUCHED THAT ENDS UP IN
YOUR HUMAN RESOURCES DEPARTMENT
OR IN PUBLIC RELATIONS AND THE
GOAL WITHOUT QUESTION TO CREATE
A RACE WAR.
THIS LANGUAGE IS NOT ABOUT
UNITING A COUNTRY, IT'S ABOUT
SPLITTING IT AND MAKING SURE
THAT IT ENDS VIOLENTLY, CAN YOU
IMAGINE HAVING HER, YOU KNOW,
SHE HAS PATIENTS.
IT CAN YOU IMAGINE IF SHE WAS
YOUR ANALYST?
SHE'S ACTUALLY TALKING ABOUT HER
WHITE PATIENTS PUBLICLY, NOT
USING THEIR NAMES BUT LUMPING
THEM IN AND DESCRIBING THEM AS
GUILT-RIDDEN, BREAD-REJECTING
FREAKS WHICH WHEN YOU
GENERICALLY APPLY A CERTAIN KIND
OF IDENTITY TO A GROUP THAT'S
NEGATIVE, THAT'S RACIST.
SHE WAS BASICALLY DEMEANING ALL
OF HER WHITE PATIENTS.
IMAGINE HOW QUICKLY A WHITE MD
WOULD BE DISBARRED IF HE HAD
POLITICALLY, PUBLICLY, I'M
SORRY, SMEARED HIS BLACK
PATIENTS.
IF YOU GOT UP THERE AND SAID
"YOU KNOW THE PROBLEM WITH MY
BLACK PATIENTS?
THAT PERSON WOULD CORNED.
THIS ISN'T A BACKLASH, IT'S US
TALKING ABOUT IT WHILE YALE
COVERS IT UP, SHE CONFESSED --
BY THE WAY, IN HER DEFENSE ABOUT
IT BEING OUT OF CONTEXT, WHAT
SHE'S TRYING TO SAY IS ONCE I
BELIEVE WAS A PERSON SO CONSUMED
WITH ANGER AND SHE'S CONFESSING
IT NOW, SHE'S TELLING YOU THIS
IS HOW I FEEL BECAUSE I HATE
WHITE PEOPLE SO MUCH AND THAT'S
THE CONTEXT.
THE PROBLEM IS, SHE IDENTIFIES
HER PROBLEM BUT NOT THE SOURCE
AND HER SOURCES THIS OBSESSION
WITH RACE.
THE MORE PEOPLE BECOME OBSESSED
WITH RACE, THE MORE OF THIS
DELUSION AND ANTIPATHY AND
HATRED WILL SPREAD AND ITS
DEMONIC.
WHEN YOU HEAR THAT YOU FEEL THE
PRESENCE, IT'S DEMONIC.
>> Katie: SEAN?
>> Sean: I WANT TO BRING UP A
COUPLE POINTS, THE NAME OF THE
SPEECH AT YALE WAS "THE CYCLE
PSYCHOPATHIC PROBLEM OF THE
WHITE MIND."
WHAT CONSUMES ME AS YOU HAVE ALL
THESE LITTLE KIDS ACROSS AMERICA
WHO ARE BEING TAUGHT THAT THE
WHITE SUPREMACIST BECAUSE THEY
ARE WHITE OR THEY ARE RACIST
BECAUSE THEY ARE WHITE, HOW
DESTRUCTIVE IS THAT FOR THOSE
CHILDREN?
BUT THE DEMOCRAT PARTY IS
PUSHING THIS IDEOLOGY AND THEY
HAVE A LONG HISTORY AS RACIST,
SEGREGATIONIST, THEY SUPPORTED
JIM CROW AND THEY ARE DOING THE
SAME THING HERE IN A DIFFERENT
WAY, NOW THEY'VE SWITCHED FROM
BLACK AND GONE TO WHITES BUT
THIS IS THE M.O. OF DEMOCRATS,
RACISM, SEGREGATION, SEPARATION
ON RACE AND IT WILL DESTROY OUR
COUNTRY.
>> Katie: IT COMES DOWN TO
IDENTITY POLITICS WHICH IS
MANIFESTING ITSELF IN